hello I'm Eric weisstein from Wolfram
research and today I will be giving a
talk jointly with Michael trot about
using quantities and units in the
Wolfram language
hello good afternoon I'm Eric weisstein
I work here at Wolfram world research
have for some time I'm talking to you
today about using units and physical
quantities in the Wolfram language so
there's a couple points I want to
emphasize up front one is I've been
involved in many aspects of this work
but a number of my colleagues have done
large parts of it
Michael Trott has been integral to every
part of it throughout the phase and I
will just thank my colleagues at the end
who've made this possible the other is
that unlike some of the other Talk's
today I'm not going to talk exclusively
about new functionality in fact a lot of
it has been in there for several
versions but I think it's
underappreciated or at least underused
in the world at large so hopefully this
will give you an overview of the sorts
of things that we've done and make you
interested and make you think that it's
useful to you so some of the things
that's not new is that both Wolfram
Alpha and the Wolfram language contain
what is almost certainly the world's
most comprehensive collection of curated
and computable units and also as I just
mentioned that the language the Wolfram
language itself contains tools that
allow you to use these and manipulate
them in useful and powerful ways so
there are a few things that's no the few
things that are new if you don't know
what a quantity variable or a quantity
variable dimension is don't worry about
it I'll show you when we get there but
they've been improved there are other
improvements coming in the current
version and then I will talk about one
new thing as the last part of the talk
which is a new entity domain devoted to
physical constants which are related to
units in fairly important and
fundamental ways so kind of a breakdown
of the talk first I'm going to talk
about unit advantage this is what's
known as a quantity I'll talk about some
custom quantity functions that can be
useful in certain applications and are
probably not used as much as they could
or should be by current unit users talk
about physical quantities which are
known in the Wolfram language is
quantity variable and then I'll talk
a little bit about this new physical
constant domain so units the units in
the Wolfram language are based on a very
extensive curated over many years
collection of units from Wolfram Alpha
collected for Wolfram Alpha the base
system has 25,000 units in it by the
time they're exposed to the Wolfram
language they get massaged we remove
compounding and such so the numbers
significantly different but what we
start with is about a curated set of
25,000 units people generally know what
units is you got your meters feet
Russian for shocks u.s. dollars is very
popular and when we say curate or know
about a unit these are the things that
we have to curate so we have a numerical
value with correct precision we know
relationship to other units we give
Spelling's associated physical
quantities which are things that these
things can be units of some formatting
and also various information about usage
so in the Wolfram language units are
encoded by a numeric magnitude which is
called a quantity magnitude together
with a unit name which is called a
quantity unit and the way that the units
are specified is by these camelcase
strings and notice their plurals for the
units and for the ones that are physical
constants acting as units they're
singular this is useful and important to
know for efficiency reasons and then
when you combine these to get compound
units you can sort of do it in an
algebraic way using x divided power etc
so when you combine these two things
together you get something called a
quantity and here are some examples of
quantities quantity speed of light you
can see it has some formatting if I
mouse over it you probably can't see
that but it gives me a little tooltip
saying the name
same thing with ohms I can use quantity
magnitude on that guy and get back one
good I can do quantity unit on it good
and I get back Ohm's I take a compound
unit which is probably getting too far
down for you to see but you get the idea
there number of ways that you can enter
these so one is you can actually type
them in quantity
whatever we have a nice feature if you
don't give a new American number you
just give the string it assumes it's one
you can do Auto completion so I can just
stop typing quantity my here and again
it's probably too small to see but you
can see you get a little pop up in some
nice ordered list you can do freeform
input so I can do my control equals two
ohms and you see one nice thing here
this is actually going out to the
Wolfram Alpha website and it's asking me
did I mean electric ohms or acoustic
ohms so it gives you the ability to sort
of query the database and find out what
you meant and the end result is going to
be that quantity object again so another
method that is often used but maybe it's
not the one you should use is quantity
unit canonicalization so you notice here
I just have a string and I put m and if
I look at that well that worked that
gave me meters but what it actually did
is did a call to the server and
translated it so you can tell which
units are known to the system with this
handy unit known unit Q and it's okay to
use this feature to discover the unit
but if you're using it in production
code try to use the standard syntax it
will be much faster especially if you're
calling it thousands of times what's
that
where we should have a way to do that at
the moment as far as I know we don't I
could be wrong about that but okay so we
also have mixed unit and magnitude so
the speaker might have this height in
certain archaic systems of Units we can
represent it using mixed magnitude and
mixed unit we can convert it to SI and
because there is an exact conversion
between Si and US customary length units
we get an exact number so we preserve
exactly an exact out when possible you
can of course and Ameri sized it as you
wish then we have this useful concept of
independent units so cows chickens pigs
well from technology conferences you may
have a unit that you want to carry
around it's basically one but it's a
counting unit so let's introduce you
know independent unit wolfram technology
conferences per year we can multiply
that by the quantity ten years
and yep we should have about ten of
those in one decade so that's a handy
thing to know about so let's just do an
example let's take a particular entity
from the pulsar data domain let's get
all of the properties and let's look at
their units so these are actually used
by astronomers any astronomers in the
audience particularly the radio
persuasion have seen Jann's keys before
the rest and you probably haven't but we
have to support all of them and so we do
and you can see they're compounds
compounds in here mixed units so we
really have a very extensive system and
this is absolutely necessary to have all
these in order to be able to curate our
data and we need more than meters and
seconds we need obscure units like this
as well okay so these are just a couple
cute graphs I apologize in advance
they're probably too small but they give
a on a logarithmic scale did this nice
plot is due to Michael Troy a list of
unit popularity on the Wolfram Alpha
website so US dollars is most popular
I guess not surprising as you move down
here seconds meters percent but you can
see it's got kind of this long tail here
so people use all kinds of units in all
kinds of disciplines and we we think we
do a really good job of supporting them
all an interest of time I'll skip the
next diagram but that's also very
interesting okay what what do you do why
do you need units what can you do when
you have one well unit conversion of
course on Wolfram Alpha and in many
simple applications is something you
want to do so the way that works is you
just use unit convert you type in your
quantity and the unit you want to go to
and I typed in an approximate machine
precision number so that's what I get
out I can also specify a target unit so
or a symbolic SI I get back an SI unit
that is a nice magnitude or I can say
let's go to SI base that will go to the
SI base similarly if I don't give one
it's basically the same as SI base so we
assume most people in the world would
like to convert by default to this nice
system of units that all but three
countries in the world use and maybe all
of them will use it someday
all right so there's also another type
of conversion you can do which is via
quantity magnitude so let's say I want
to know how many kilometres is 26.2
miles well I could convert it and then
strip off the units but why would I want
to do that
so there's this handy second argument to
quantity magnitude this is give me the
magnitude of this expressed in this
unit's and so there's just another
example doing it with time units we can
also do currency conversions so let's
and this requires internet connectivity
because you have to actually see what
the current exchange rate is so if all
is good
in this one let's see what the actual
underlying okay that's what we got
that's what both let's see what full
form of it is okay so it seems to be a
machine precision number I'm not sure
that's technically correct but that's
what whatever service we use gives us
yes so and actually you can do something
you can do what's called a dated unit so
I can say give me what a euro was into
now in 2015 US dollars so it was a
little bit less and so I'm converting
today's Euros to 2015 I believe it's the
first of January yes I'm not sure how
fine-grained our data is on historical
conversions but it's at least fine
enough to get it on a yearly basis so if
I would ask what is the conversion
between euros and dollars between two
thousand two thousand fifteen there's
what it looks like started off not so
good went strong and looks like it's
leveling off and you can do the same for
you know compare US dollars what was one
US dollar in 1800 worth today
well that's 20 bucks so a dollar
definitely went a lot further back then
than it does now you can do the same
with dates so I can say - what's today
plus a hundred days and I guess the
stylesheet wants to show that infinitely
small but it did the right thing I gave
me another date object but a hundred
days away from today I could do the same
with now and men
it's unit simplification is another
thing that you might want to do so let's
say I have this quantity I can apply
units simplify to it and it by default
it does something rational like
converting to standard SI unit
joule-seconds is another one you might
want to simplify so all these will be
available in the notebook if I'm going
too fast if I do a basic expansion into
the SI base units of joules you can see
it has those dimensions but we also have
a higher level function called unit
dimensions that will give you the actual
sort of dimensional pieces that this
thing corresponds to at the moment these
are sort of factor integer like objects
with strings as the first argument we
hope to expand this a little bit in the
future that's very useful and we have a
lot of functions that build on to that
we can also do unit simplify so radians
and revolutions are a constant source of
consternation for we by default we treat
revolutions and radians as actual units
that we carry around but if we want to
treat the angle unit as unity we can
specify an option to unit simplify that
says I'm gonna treat radians as one and
it converted it off into into pies so
what can I do with these things within
the system well a growing number of
functions inside the Wolfram language
know about these solve does you can do
more complicated examples like this one
from a recent archived reprint about the
critical number density of black holes
in the universe which turns out to be
about at 0.3 Planck temperature you're
left with only black holes dissolved
knows about it so I can give you knitted
quantities here and the result comes
back with units I can plug back in
things again be careful about this our
radians equal to 1 or they equal to 2
pie issue
and then quantity array so let's say you
have a huge data set with with lots of
unity objects you don't want to carry
around the unit's all the time so if you
have a lot of them
you can make one of these quantity array
objects and that is an efficient wrapper
that has sort of similar ways of
accessing it into a quantity magnitude
quantity units on it but represents the
data in a very efficient way they can
have mixed units if I call normal on it
I get it out I can send it to a common
set of units and I can convert it back
to a quantity array so where this is
used in particular right now but could
be used lots of other places is things
like geo elevation data where I'm
getting all the data around Denver and I
want to represent it efficiently and I
want to be able to plot it and again for
some reason my stylesheet has made
everything really teeny but this
provides a very efficient way to
represent manipulate the data
similarly for distributions the
probability related functionality works
much better for United quantities if I
type something in here that actually has
units what will come out is a quantity
distribution as opposed to just a normal
distribution and that allows sort of all
the all the unit stuff to be
automatically propagated through without
you having to worry about it this was
just an example to show a little bit
more how that works I think I'm gonna
have to leave that for you to read in
the notebook and move on to physical
quantities so most people probably know
about physical quantities they might not
have heard it called that but these are
the things that sort of units measure so
speed length force induction they get
very obscure and we have about 2200 of
them and of course some units measure
more than one physical quantity that's
all handled we know all about that
they are also represented by a camelcase
string good we're consistent here now
wrapped instead of quantity they're
wrapped inside of something called a
quantity variable and this includes
again sort of sub cases so we have
lengths but we know bond length we know
coherence length this makes it sort of
very easy to carry around information
about what my unit is representing in
addition to its value and again I can
enter that using input form I can use
command completion or I can use
freeform input and if I type just mass
in my little input cell it will
automatically figure out that's what I
meant and translated appropriately okay
so this where to go this is a nice
visualization made by Michael I've
selected meter second and kilogram and
I'm looking at all physical quantities
we have in the system that have those
those things as combine in combination
in their physical quantities so you can
see the space is very interesting we can
plot this in 2d or 3d and the the the
guts of it is really in the middle right
as you go into the middle the things
with low powers length two speeds
there's a there's a bit see what's that
surface energy force gradient there a
lot that use that that just gives you a
way to visualize kind of the the space
of physical quantities that we're trying
to cover a large consumer of these that
has been appeared in a couple of talks
is formula data so I've just extracted a
few random samples there I can pull out
a particular formula for resistivity and
this is what it looks like internally so
if again if I mouse over it's probably
going to show me a little tooltip saying
that's an electric conductivity that's
the resistivity this is internally how
it's represented and the nice thing
about that is is that it's very easy so
let's take Ohm's law again it's very
easy to sort of plug things in use
built-in functions to solve and get
answers in the way that you want
so Ohm's law includes these three
quantity variable identifiers and if I
want to actually get Ohm's law but plug
in some values and solve it I can
immediately do it just like this so a
formula data is a heavy consumer of
units and quantities physical systems
data is another one this is the
Hamiltonian functions of a double
pendulum as I mouse over each one of
these you see that is actually a
physical quantity those are the physical
quantities in there and this is the
whole thing in it's beautiful
tagged glory thanks to Tony ok so I have
a physical quantity I'd like to know
what's its canonical unit we can do that
it's a rather long name but it's
consistent with all our other naming
that's quantity variable canonical unit
they're probably command completes if
you don't feel like typing the whole
thing and then we have an analogue you
can also ask for the dimensions of a
physical quantity and mass times
acceleration looks like a length mass
per time squared so that looks about
right some of these are overloaded in a
little bit so let's let's say that I
have this set of quantity variables if I
just apply it to this wave function you
see it's length unit to the minus 1 the
nice thing is I can also apply the
derivative to it and quantity variable
dimensions is smart enough to kind of go
inside and propagate that a very nice
and useful function dimensional
combinations is due to Jason Martinez
you can ask for dimensionally equivalent
physical quantities so let's see I have
a force I think it's related to electric
charge distance and something called
electric eel a stivity and yep that
looks pretty much like Coulomb's law
maybe modulo factors of whatever but
those that's dimensionally equivalent or
if I want to say force is related
somehow I think to mass distance in time
there you go dimensional combinations is
your friend I could do the same to find
the relate the size of mushroom cloud to
when I measured it and how much energy
the bomb that made it was I think that's
called a Taylor set-off equation or
something like that and I can also
discover famous or not so famous numbers
that are known in various fields of
engineering and other things so I've
pulled out the formula for the Reynolds
number those are the physical quantities
inside and asked for dimensional
combinations all but the first one which
is what I'm looking for and there we go
there's basically Reynolds the
Reynolds number modulo [ __ ] you can
also do more fun things like let's take
all the physical quantities the standard
ones and look for if there are any
combinations of them well there are the
electric constant magnetic constant and
speed of light are related
turns out exactly by that relationship
or if you want to find a more general
one let's just include this set of
physical quantities there's a more
general form of it which I've never seen
before
alright so physical constants is
switching gears a little bit in the
sense that what I've been talking about
before are built-in objects whereas this
is an entity object and it's a way to
kind of solve the problem that we can
compute with units but often times when
it comes to things like the geoid of the
earth or something you need to know
which value you're using it might change
over time as a standards body changed
and so you want to be able to have sort
of more entity like properties so this
is a new entity table that was added
back in August it's meant to help
standardize and make easier to update
basically the unit tables in the whole
unit system and it has about 200
constants right now and there are ways
to go back and forth we kind of have
this duality with regard to physical
constants we have a dance unit form and
in this entity form so most of the time
you know what you want but if not you
can go back and forth so here's a
something proving my statement we have
about 200 here's a random list of them
and here is a table I guess of the first
10 alphabetically not so interesting all
atomic units but you can see again here
we're integrally using the unit system
okay so here list of properties of these
guys a very important one is the primary
source a lot of them are not too
controversial but there are ones where
if you do research for the DoD they
require you to specify which standard
body you used for certain ones and
reference it so we have that now we have
link also to the standard so there you
go there's a speed of light you can you
can ask for this is a quantity so
there's the entity and I and one
property is quantity and that returns it
in quantity form or I can ask for it in
value and standard uncertainty and this
one is kind of special because it's
exactly defined and I have a few more
examples so of course these it being
entities they have various classes that
can ask for all cosmological constants
in the system which is something you
couldn't do when this was all purely in
the unit's world and here is kind of an
example of what I was talking about it's
too small to read but the point is the
Planck constant is something that's
experimentally measured at least for now
and codata is one of the primary sources
the value has stayed the same over time
but the uncertainty keeps getting
smaller so the measurements are getting
better so you can historically see how
the standard values of this have changed
over time you can pick which one you
want to use and here's a particularly
interesting part known to probably some
of you that it has been proposed this
become one of the standard exactly
defined constants in an SI proposal made
last year not yet implemented but there
are plans to redefine a number of the
base units or base physical constants
that sort of shuffle things around so
having this entity table in place kind
of allows us to under the hood update to
those when the time comes yes so I
showed an example where it said what was
it standard or whatever it will choose
the most recent code 801 in general but
there's a property of the entity that
tells you which one is the standard one
but you can also get access to all of
them we also have this fun thing the
fine-structure constant or inverse of it
is some of you know has historically
interesting and popular having been
fairly close to an integer so within
this table we also list conjectured
values
it's probably the most complete list
some of them tongue-in-cheek not serious
but we have them we don't do things part
way we do them all the way so I said you
probably most of you are not familiar
with to entity and from entity they
provide convenient ways to go from the
entity world to kind of the proper
Mathematica symbol world so I went from
a quantity using two entity and what I
got back was the entity and similarly
went from an entity of the gravitational
constant and I got back a quantity so I
said that a little fast but this works
within in a number of domains you can do
it with graphs you can do with various
other things if you haven't seen it look
up to an Indian from entity these also
contain as I mentioned explicit
uncertainty tagging I still have a
minute or two to get away with thanks so
here's a list of some of the standard
constants and what their uncertainty and
relatively uncertainty is which with
Jose's beautiful about or around or
whatever it will be called functionality
will make a really handy way to encode
this all in one place without needing
separate properties and so on and to be
automatically propagated so future work
there's still more physical constants to
be at it there are more function out so
speeding up parsing of units there are
some things there some bottlenecks right
now where we could do things more
efficiently and reduce dependence on the
web so that will be a high priority the
number of functions including those in
visualization fitting and such would
benefit from knowing about units without
you having to kind of take them out and
then put them back in at the end so
hopefully that will come there's going
to be a nice new function to basically
take expressions and non Dement them in
non dimensionalized form so for instance
you'll be able to take this differential
equation that has quantities in it and
what we turn back one that has purely
scalars but tells you how to go from the
scalars to the quantity versions in nice
way and that's pretty much all I had to
say I know I went rather fast but maybe
I have time for
one or two questions and thank you for
your attention oh like the most
important slide these are some of the
people who've made this all possible so
Jose makes a lot of it work in the
Wolfram language Nick does a lot of the
interface and also makes it works in the
Wolfram language Jason Martinez has done
non dimensionalizing Jorn sort of makes
it work on the Wolfram Alpha side and
Michael does all of it keeps it all
moving okay thank you